e
[Aplausos]
é uma alegria estar aqui hoje para falar
para você sobre envelhecer E aí perdi
você já só com a primeira palavra eu
pergunto isso porque o assunto
envelhecer ele afugenta as pessoas
e tudo ficou mais simples para mim
quando eu decidir encarar um monstro
isso mesmo que eu falei monstro porque é
assim que envelhecer é visto ele é visto
como algo assustador
e eu também percebi que para a gente tem
um bom envelhecimento a gente precisa
ter saco
saúde autoestima
coragem e Ousadia
e ele não estaria aqui hoje se eu não
tivesse colocado o tal monstro no saco e
também não estaria aqui hoje se eu não
tivesse superado ou melhor aceitado
aquele momento diante do espelho que
você olha e fala meu Deus ferrou todo
mundo quer viver muito tempo mas ninguém
quer ser velho não é assim
pois é eu percebi
que além de não querer ser velho a gente
não quer parecer velho hoje eu tenho 55
anos e a coragem de ser tenso ou seja
uma mulher 50 mais que não é e nem quer
ser uma menininha aliás mulher que não é
e nem quer ser uma menininha tá na
descrição do vídeo a coroa o canal que
eu queria para entender melhor o meu
envelhecer e como para mim amor e humor
são fundamentais eu a inventei esse nome
viva a coroa você gosta pois é muitas
pessoas
detestaram coroa que a gíria para mulher
mais velha ainda soa pejorativo para
muita gente mas você sabe né coroa
também a símbolo de poder e de muito
poder o movimento pró idade ele cresce
com força diariamente tá no Vivo a coroa
tá em outros canais está nos filmes está
na Série está nas pesquisas É algumas
marcas começaram acordar para isso e
isso é uma super boa notícia para quem é
50 mais por outro lado ainda existem
alguns métodos
dietas
cremes que são chamadas de anti-idade e
isso nos deixa confusos né
e também existem essas máximas que que
são frases que foram surgindo
para a gente entender melhor essa fase
eu entendo que essa confusão acontece
porque nós estamos no meio dessa
revolução prateada E essas máximas são
coisas do tipo a idade está na cabeça
bom mas eu posso garantir para você aqui
hoje quando eu acordei a minha idade
estava aqui na minha lombar às vezes ela
tá na minha visão e às vezes ela tá aqui
aqui depende do dia também tem aquela
outra que puxa a minha idade não me
define tudo bem sua idade e suas regras
mas para mim você bem Franca minha idade
me define sim mas ela não me limita que
não seria eu se não fosse todo meio
milhão de horas que eu já vivi nesse 55
anos de vida tá tudo lá dentro alegria
tristeza osso
e
retomadas as paixões tudo lá
a retalhista o preconceito contra idade
é um entrave e pode contaminar até os
mais velhos isso precisa mudar essa
mudança de olhar essa mudança de
mentalidade precisa a partir de dentro
de nós eu vou te contar uma história
Era uma vez uma mulher com trinta e
poucos anos que se sentiu velha pela
primeira vez essa mulher era eu a
empresa que eu trabalhava foi comprada
por um grupo e eu me senti velha porque
chegaram aqueles novos colegas de
trabalho cheio de diplomas e com todo o
tempo do mundo eu já era uma trintona
mãe e trabalhava desde os 18 anos de
idade e de repente me vi me senti velha
me sentir ameaçada pelos colegas mais
jovens
bom então tem a cereja do bolo um dia eu
atendo o telefone uma central PABX quem
é 50 mais aqui sabe que tinha uma
central PABX Mas eu vejo poucos vou
tentar mais hoje e aí a pessoa me disse
a senhora pode anotar um recado falei
senhora Como assim o cara tá lá do outro
lado da linha ele não tá nem me vendo
como é que ele pode tá me chamando de
senhora
então
bar ser chamada de senhora aos 30 me
pegou
e a juventude Ela é glamourizada o tempo
todo no mundo inteiro para todos os
lados que você olha é jovem jovem jovem
jovem no trabalho na mídia e até na
nossa memória a gente escolhe se lembrar
mas quando o amor das coisas quando a
gente era mais jovem né E foi sofrido
para mim ser chamada de senhora aos 30
anos mas também foi bom porque
acendeu em mim uma vontade de fazer
mudanças e um tempo depois eu deixei
esse emprego e foi estudar design de
interiores uma paixão então Três anos
depois eu me formei e passei de autônoma
a lojista e foi Bárbaro foi um super
sucesso
até que se sucesso virou um fracasso é
né obviamente não é o que acontece com
todo mundo mas acontece bastante foi o
que aconteceu
e
esse fracasso me derrubou eu caí
despenquei fiquei deprimida eu viver uma
fase de luto
e até que eu percebi que eu precisava me
reerguer
e entrei para um grupo de WhatsApp de
muitas mulheres mais de 100 e era uma
festa né tudo que a gente colocava ali
naquele grupo todo mundo celebrava que
maravilha qualquer coisa pequena ou
grande é uma grande celebração
isso foi Mar em bando e foi devolvendo a
minha luz própria que andava um pouco
apagadinha eu fui me animando e de
repente resolvi estudar fotografia
me vi lá no consulado americano pedindo
um visto de estudante aos 52 anos a
pessoa me pediu né todos aqueles
documentos aquela pilha né que a gente
tem que levar essas todo mundo que já
pediu visto no Consulado Americano sabe
disso
Oi e o uma mulher em torno dos 40 anos
começou a fazer aquele questionário né
52 anos
estudando sozinha
e é eu falei seus filhos vão ficar com
quem
não os meus filhos vão ficar com pai mas
eles são praticamente adultos né Ah é E
o seu marido seu marido te apoia
e ele apoia mas aí eu fiquei pensando
gente que que eu tô fazendo de errado né
só quer um visto de estudante
e
começou ela começou a mexer com aquela
papelada toda um silêncio e eu ali quase
sem respirar né de repente ela quebrou o
silêncio
e me falou puxa eu tenho filhos e poder
ter um tempo só para mim bem que eu
gostaria e foi aí que eu entendi que era
sobre ela e que a minha coragem também
estava abrindo a porta uma outra mulher
e que quando uma mulher se reconhece na
outra o mundo pode ser melhor
bom Nos olhamos trocamos sorrisos eu
conseguiu visto e as baby yeah I got me
fui para Los Angeles fazer esse curso de
fotografia e fui morar sozinha pela
primeira vez na vida aos 52 anos é a
minha turma de fotografia em geral tinha
20 vinte e poucos anos e foi muito
interessante perceber como essa troca
entre gerações esse Mix é importante e
que cada idade tem a sua luz e tem a sua
sombra também né tem seus Monstros eu
entendi isso na prática e isso foi a
fagulha inicial para minha ideia do Viva
a coroa mas nada aconteceu por acaso
Olha eu parei para pensar
fiz conta parei para pensar mais um
pouco pesquisei sonhei duvidei de mim
até que eu finalmente
resolvi colocar em prática
e hoje eu sou uma influência coroa uma
vida nas redes sociais Eu nunca imaginei
eu nem sabia que existia essa
possibilidade para mim
Eu fiz curso de datilografia uma máquina
manual Então acho que isso já mostra a
distância que a minha cabeça tava de ser
uma influência Depois dos 50 anos os
meus filhos viu meu marido dizem assim
você tá tão mudada depois do Vivo a
coroa
Oi e eu digo é verdade eu tô super
mudada eu me sinto mais assertiva eu me
sinto mais confiante eu me sinto mais
feliz eu fico mais feliz ainda quando eu
percebo que eu não sou a única mulher
mudada nos postos do Viva a coroa você
encontra mulheres que começaram a fazer
faculdade agora mulheres que resolveram
retomar os estudos mulheres que estão
fazendo cursos de dança dança do ventre
ou dance e voltaram a namorar tenho
centenas de exemplos diariamente tem
pelo menos um ou dois de de mulheres se
reinventando Depois dos 50
bom então quando me perguntam o que que
é possível fazer um dia depois dos 50
anos eu costumo responder com uma outra
pergunta vamos lá o que que não é
possível fazer Depois dos 50 né Tem
muitas mulheres aí para nos provar que é
possível fazer muita coisa a Luiza
Helena Trajano só cresce e agora é a
única brasileira na lista dos 100 mais
influentes da revista Time A Elza Soares
continua brilhando né Aos 90 anos a
Mirian goldenberg lançou mais um livro
esse ano e tem também a Marineide que é
conhecida como fora sineide uma
maratonista que criou o Projeto Vida
corrida e com ele transformou muitas
vidas a começar pela dela mesmo
e eu admiro e me inspiro em mulheres que
vivem o próprio envelhecimento sem
preconceitos e principalmente sem ditar
regras e criticar tem agem de forma
diferente e não ter preconceito não
significa ter que deixar os cabelos
brancos não significa fazer uma ordem as
rugas né isso eu externo e o externo é
uma escolha de cada um cada pessoa pode
envelhecer do jeito que quiser
Sabe aquela mentira que a juventude é o
melhor da vida pois é a juventude acaba
a infância acaba a velhice acaba E aí
desculpa dizer uma obviedade não tem
próxima fase Essa é a realidade A
maturidade me trouxe essa luz e muitas
outras eu acredito que uma boa velhice
está apoiada em poucos mas
indispensáveis fatores mobilidade a
comissão de consciência
e resumo só tem um fator realmente
fundamental que pode atrapalhar uma boa
velhice que é a saúde física e mental
é parte importante de saúde em todas as
idades mas a gente sabe muito bem que na
velhice a saúde fica mais frágil
bom e que o mais importante de tudo é o
auto cuidado que que a gente tem de mais
importante para fazer do que cuidar de
nós mesmos
Eu mesmo não tenho essa resposta
a ciência está evoluindo mas essa
manutenção ela dá trabalho ela exige
dedicação e Coragem coragem para que
coragem para fazer algo novo começar a
dançar voltar a dançar aprender uma nova
língua coragem para dizer não coragem
para dizer sim né E mais a coragem
desperta aquela doce rebeldia que ajuda
a derreter os tabus
e quando eu comecei a postar o viva
coroa eu vi a cada coisa né você vai
falar disso mas quem que quer ouvir
falar sobre isso o isso era envelhecer
né Às vezes eu ficava Incomodada com
aquela rejeição mas eu ouvi a refletir a
e em frente hoje eu fico pensando se eu
tivesse dado ouvidos aquelas críticas
Sem questionar Talvez o Vivo a coroa e
nem existisse
a Simone de bovoa dizia que para lidar
com a velhice é preciso manter o que dá
sentido à Vida em todas as fases e o que
que dá sentido à Vida as pessoas os
relacionamentos as causas a
produtividade as paixões estar aberta
para o novo Depois dos 50 ajuda muito
impulsiona
aprender a ouvir o que me desagrada foi
tão importante quanto saber que dizer
não às vezes e também ok e que Ok não
agradar todo mundo
o tempo enfraqueceu a minha pretensão de
saber tudo e deixou mais vivo o meu
desejo de aprender mais e de sonhar um
futuro
o filósofo Sêneca tem uma frase muito
linda que fala o valor da vida e do
valor do agora
O que é assim apressa-te a viver bem e
pensa que cada dia é por si só uma vida
depende de nós coroas e do nosso saco
é obrigado a